putin hasn't murdered 18 to 20 million
people
and the scale of his abilities to cause
grief
uh
with the nuclear weapons aside is
nothing like stalin's and so we have to
be careful right only mal
put bigger numbers on the board
from a tragic point of view than stalin
and numbers matter here
if we compare these singular figures
yeah mal killed more people than stalin
because mao had more people to kill
the most amazing thing about mao is he
watched stalin do it
he watched stalin collectivize
agriculture and famine result
he watched stalin impose this communist
monopoly
and all of those people sent to prison
or given a bullet in the back of the
neck he watched all of that and then he
did it again himself in china do you
think he saw the human cost directly
that that when you say he saw do you
think he was focused on the policies
or was he also aware distinctly as a
human being of the
human costs in the lives of peasants and
the in the lives of the working class
and lives of the poor
i think the prima facie evidence is that
he didn't value human life
otherwise i don't think after seeing the
amount of lives that were taken in the
soviet experiment he would have done
something similar after that
i think the answer lex is
it's very hard to get inside mal's head
and figure out what he was really
thinking
but if you just look at the results that
happened the policies that were
undertaken and the consequences of them
you would have to conclude that there
was
let's say no value or little value
placed on human life
unfortunately that's characteristic not
only of communist dictators right of
post-communist dictators as well but the
scale
of the horrors that they inflict
as horrific as they are just can't
compare
and so we're in a situation where
eurasia
that is to say
the ancient civilizations of eurasia
which would be russia iran
china
all have
some version of non-democratic you know
illiberal autocratic regimes
and they're all pushing up against the
greater power of the west in some form
sometimes they coordinate their actions
and sometimes they don't
but this is a very long-standing
phenomenon likes the predates
of vladimir putin or xi jinping
or the latest incarnation of the supreme
leader in iran
you